Hey there, thanks for listening.
Before we jump into this episode, I just want to remind you that this episode is brought
to you by us over at TalkBython Training and Brian through his PyTest book.
So if you want to get hands on and learn something with Python, be sure to consider our courses
over at TalkBython Training.
Visit them via pythonbytes.fm/courses.
And if you're looking to do testing and get better with PyTest, check out Brian's book
at pythonbytes.fm/pytest.
by the episode.
- Hello and welcome to Python Bytes,
where we deliver Python news and headlines
directly to your earbuds.
This is episode 247, recorded August 25th.
Really?
Oh, we're almost done.
And 2021.
I'm Brian Okken.
- I'm Michael Kennedy.
- And I'm Dan Taylor.
- So Dan, before we jump into things,
welcome to the show.
But can you let people know kind of who you are?
- Yeah, thank you.
It's great to be here.
A big fan of the show.
So I'm Dan Taylor.
I'm a program manager manager on our Python team.
So I manage a team of program managers
that work on our Python developer tools.
For example, our Python support and Visual Studio Code
and Visual Studio IDE.
And we also manage some of our engagements
with the Python community.
For example, our sponsorships of PyCon
and the Python Software Foundation.
- That's awesome.
You know something Dan, I thought was pretty interesting.
I was just watching a talk from Brett Cannon,
getting ready for an interview I did on Talk Python
with Xlinga, a lot of stuff going on there.
But the talk was only from 2018 and Brett went into detail
describing what VS Code was,
I was like, Atom or Sublime and all these things.
It needs no introduction these days, does it?
- No, no, it's just been amazing watching
just how much it's grown over the past year
and it become a household name for people,
especially in the Python community.
- Definitely.
- Well, Michael, how do I keep my computer awake?
- Well, first you make sure it gets eight hours
of sleep a day.
You don't overwork it.
I know it's work from home,
so you might be working on it,
playing on it and watching TV.
Oh wait, this is not,
this is a totally different thing.
So I recently was working on this project
around some of the courses over at Talk Python Training,
and I needed to do a bunch of video processing
and re-encoding for like,
take the same videos, but make them smaller.
So I wrote some really cool Python code to go through
and pick the source videos and do all this analysis
and re-encode it into a bunch of formats.
You know, that takes like five hours for one of our courses.
And if my computer goes to sleep, it's going to take more than five hours.
I got to go and like, keep waking the thing up again.
Right.
Well, what can I do?
I could go into the settings and say, you know what?
Don't do that.
Just don't go to sleep right now, but then maybe I'll forget.
Who knows?
It would be cool if just while my Python code was running, it would stay awake.
And then it would potentially not stay awake when it was done.
Wouldn't that be nice?
Yeah.
So I found this cool library called WakePi,
and the implementation of using this is ridiculously easy.
You just say from WakePi import keep awake,
and then you create a context manager.
With keep awake, do the stuff you want it to do
while the computer doesn't go to sleep, done.
That's cool, huh?
- Seems easy.
- Yeah, it's super easy.
It works cross-platform.
It works on Windows.
It works on Linux.
It doesn't really work on Mac OS 'cause there's a bug,
but it's supposed to work on Mac OS,
which is where I'm running this right now.
So that's kind of unfortunate, wouldn't you say?
(laughing)
It turns out it's one of these strings
versus bytes weirdness.
So I actually decided this is kind of cool.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna create a PR.
There's a PR that says it doesn't work on Python 3,
but you know what?
And here's like the error if anyone cares,
you get this bytes like object is required, not string.
So I submitted a PR.
The PR is not yet addressed or responded to
or anything.
So if you wanna use this for the time being,
I can really only on macOS, to be clear,
I can only recommend it off of my branch
until you see that PR merge,
'cause it won't work at all.
But if you're using Windows or Linux,
I think it'll just work straight away.
And it's interesting if you actually dig into it,
I kind of imagined it would just be doing the same thing.
But if you dig into it, like in the Mac version,
there's literally a command you can type on,
this is awesome, you can type on the terminal,
you can type caffeinate.
that'll keep your OS from going to sleep
if you just run that on the terminal.
If you type a dash D, it'll keep the display on,
things like that, it won't let the screen go to sleep.
But over on say Windows,
it does a bunch of tweaking with threads.
So what it'll do is like go and set its current thread
to be like continuous system required,
display required as a bunch of bitwise flags.
And then over on Linux, it uses what else?
that uses something completely different.
It runs mask and unmask,
which I don't actually know what that does.
I suspect it keeps it awake.
So anyway, it's a pretty cool little project.
It's very simple, but it also solves the problem
that I can imagine a ton of people doing data science-y
like things would run into
because they wanna do a bunch of processing
and not have their system go to sleep.
What do you all think?
- I think I'm just glad that I know about Caffeinate now
'cause that's cool.
- Yeah, if you want to keep your Mac awake,
you literally just have to go over and type caffeinate
on the terminal.
You don't have to have Python or any of those kinds of things
but if you want your Python code to control it,
this thing is basically subprost juggling that command.
- Yeah, I can imagine if you're writing code
that's scraping websites, looking for updates
and things like that, you really wouldn't want
your computer to go to sleep and I always find myself
messing around in all the power settings
and maxing things out.
- Exactly.
- So this is nice.
- Yeah, yeah, very cool, very cool.
Awesome, well, that's it for that one, Brian.
- Cool.
- Off to you.
What do we got next? We have, oh, how to create a great Stack Overflow question.
Actually, this is great.
>> Yeah, Stack Overflow just sold for like $1.4 billion. It's quite the site.
>> Really? Who did it sell to? Do you know?
>> No, I don't remember. It's a company I hadn't heard of.
>> I didn't miss that.
>> Anyway, so I don't really actually, of course, when I Google stuff,
I get a bunch of Stack Overflow answers and I've utilized it.
I like tried to play the whole game for a little while of like trying to get stack overflow points and stuff
And then I realized yeah, this just isn't my thing, but it's a thing for a lot of people of like answering this
But um the reason why I brought this up isn't just to get great answers on stack overflow
But there is a good trick to that and it's good
but it's also if you're asking questions really from anybody if you if you send a any sort of expert that you know, like
maybe if you want to ask a pyramid question to michael or
or a PyTest question from me.
These sorts of things,
this is the same topics apply.
Let's just jump in. This is from Kevin Markham at Data School.
Kevin's a great guy. We hang out with him
sometimes at PyCons and stuff when we had those.
But the punchline of his article,
which we'll link to, is you need to write a brief introduction,
and you want to have self-contained code examples,
and then detail the expected results and why you want those results.
Then add any other important notes linked to relevant questions,
and then also write a title that summarizes the question.
These all seem obvious,
so I'm really glad that Kevin went through an example.
He started with an example that
one of his students asked him about pandas.
The question really was about
data frames and filling in missing values,
and it had a domain-specific thing that somebody was asking him.
Then Kevin goes through and
rewrites the question as a good Stack Overflow question,
and it's night and day.
It's amazing to see this.
I really encourage people to read the article.
But a couple of things that I really love is converting,
that he didn't really talk about,
but convert the example from
any domain-specific stuff to a toy example.
That's a good skill to have anyway,
is to say this problem that I'm having in my code,
it's really a generic problem.
How do I make that using a toy example to describe the problem?
Oftentimes, actually, you can answer
your own question once you get it into a toy example,
and you realize, "Oh, I'm overthinking it."
This is a good first step.
This is a great thing to see.
But this is a great example because it's like some architecture problem,
but then he turns it into colors of toys.
It's an easier problem to see.
The other thing is making sure that the example is
runnable with all the import statements and everything.
Somebody can just plop it into their own editor and run it to
see if they can see the same problem and see if they can figure out.
>> That's good advice. If it's too specific or you don't have the data or it's not
complete, you have to speculate rather than actually verify you can fix the problem or not.
>> Yeah. One of the things that I wouldn't have thought of is linking to other questions
because there's a fear, I think, of moderators and also other people reading it is,
if it's simple, it's probably already been answered. Did you already look or whatever?
the act of linking to other answers to say,
this question over here doesn't really,
it helps me but it's missing because of this or something.
Some reason why the other answers.
That's an interesting take on it just
to so that people don't dismiss you right away
as somebody that didn't do any research to begin with.
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> Yeah, it's cool. Usually by the time I get to
Stack Overflow I'm pretty desperate for help.
And so forming really good questions
so you get the best answers is really important.
I really like that.
Narrowing it down to a reproducible example.
- Yeah, and people can be mean on Stack Overflow
and on Reddit and on YouTube
and other places on the internet.
But if you show that you've tried,
I think that will disarm them somewhat.
- Totally.
- Right, I mean, I've seen questions like,
I have this homework question and I can't do my homework.
Could anyone help?
And I get that email too.
And they're like, no, no one can help.
- No one wants to do your homework for you.
Yeah, so no one should.
But if you have a legitimate problem
or you think you found a legitimate bug
or there's just no documentation
and it's clear you've tried,
I suspect that'll disarm people.
They may still not be able to help you,
but at least they won't be mean.
Hey, Brian, before we move on to the next one,
I wanna do two quick real-time follow-ups.
So one, Stack Overflow sold to tech giant ProSUS,
ProSUS, we've all heard of them,
for $1.8 billion.
So that is not messing around.
That forum site did all right.
Jill Spolsky and Jeff Atwood did okay.
And then the other one is,
unfortunately Dan Heifert out there in the live stream
said he just ran Caffeinate three times on his Mac
and he can't get it to sleep
and it's acting jittery and anxious.
So I don't really know what we can do about that,
but maybe we should just go to TikTok.
What do you think?
- Yeah, totally.
So have you ever really wanted to make a quick edit
to something you've got in a GitHub repo,
but you're kind of stuck with that rudimentary,
feels like you're working with Notepad, maybe a little.
- Yeah, so you click the edit, there's a little edit thing.
You find the file, you edit it, and then you go in there
and there's like no help and you just type away.
Yeah, I do that.
I don't love it, but I do that.
- Feels like you're in Notepad.
Well, GitHub announced GitHub Codespaces recently,
which is a cloud hosted development environments
with powerful machines and you have to pay for them.
But one of the fun bonus features
that they launched at the same time
that we only really announced on TikTok
and other social media is called github.dev.
So you can actually go to any GitHub repo
and say, I just wanna edit this GitHub repo that I have here.
I can just press the dot key
and that will reopen this GitHub repository
in something called github.dev.
So this is an entirely web browser-based version of VS Code
that's built right into GitHub.
It works on any GitHub repo.
And there's no server behind it, it's serverless.
So there's nothing that you need to pay for here.
And so it also has some limited functionality
'cause there's no backend.
This is all just a front end running in your web browser.
But what's really cool is that you can come in here
and you can edit, you can add new files.
Like I can go in here and add a new Python file
in the file explorer on the left.
I can just click and add a new file
and I can work with this more like I'm used to working
with a text editor.
and as I can just say, imports flask, for example.
And because we've, there's support for different extensions
that are web enabled that know how to work in this new mode.
So we've actually added the Python extension recently
in here, so I can actually get some autocomplete
from some of the modules.
So if I say from flask import flask,
I get the autocomplete for that flask object
and I can do the typical thing where I can say,
flask equals name, and I can type app.
And I get all of this, you know,
add template filter route, all those in the autocomplete.
So I can actually get a more real editing experience
with the productivity,
the things like that that I'm used to
when I'm working with text editor.
But this is all using the storage file system
from the web browser's local storage,
as well as the files from the GitHub repo.
So if, for example, if I go in here and just change
hello world, hello Python bytes in this code here
and I hit save on a piece of code
and then I see I've got source control changes here
and it's telling me that I can click on that file
and I can actually see a diff of that file side by side
and I can just commit that using the source control panel.
And if I add this commit,
it'll go directly into my GitHub repo.
So that's pretty cool.
- So a lot of the-- - That's amazing.
I do see right below the source control thing,
a play debug thing.
- So that doesn't-- - That doesn't work yet, does it?
- Yeah, so that's what there's like,
continue working on code spaces at that point.
You gotta get a real machine for,
if you wanna do things like running--
- I see, it takes you over to the hosted,
the real hosted version.
- Yeah, yeah, but there is some,
we're actually pushing the boundaries
of what you can do in these web versions
in some interesting ways.
So you can get basic syntax highlighting,
as you saw, auto-complete,
but there's no Python interpreter.
So when I go to definition, say,
I wanna go to definition on this Flask module,
it just brings up type hints,
the type hints that we have for Flask.
- I see, the TypeShed type hints, okay.
- Yeah, TypeShed type hints.
- It's still okay though, it's still better
than like what you get with a normal editor.
- Yeah, it's pretty cool.
One kind of bonus thing I wanna throw in here is that,
so if you go to the extensions tab,
you'll be able to search
and you'll see which extensions are web enabled.
And one of the fun ones that somebody on our team put out
is this VS Code PyIoDyed one.
So if you actually open a Jupyter notebook,
you can run a little bit of Python code
from these cells here using PyIoDyed.
So that's pretty neat.
- Oh, wow.
- So this is--
- WebAssembly for the win.
- Yeah, so that's github.dev.
I think it's really cool how much more you can do
right from the browser within GitHub.
I'm excited to see where this goes.
- Brian, did you know about this?
- I didn't, and I was just playing with it
the background on my own repo.
I was looking through the extensions,
and maybe you know off the top of your head, Dan,
can I get the Vim mode in this extension?
>> Well, you'll see which ones are.
If they're highlighted here and not grayed out,
so this Vim extension works.
You can see which ones are available.
It says available in VS Code Web.
>> You just made Brian's day.
There's a couple of Vim options.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I just can't use any editor without Venmo anymore.
>> My brain just doesn't work without.
>> How do you use Google Docs or other editors or anything like that?
>> What's that?
>> How do you use Google Docs or some other editor?
>> I paste into that after I've written the stuff in somewhere else.
>> Nice. Dan, when I first saw this,
I was on my GitHub repo and I'm like,
"Oh, let me just hit dot because it seems like that's too simple,
but I'll try it." Then boom, it became an editor.
I'm like, oh my God, this is awesome.
And then I went into the settings
and I put it into dark mode
and I changed the font size and all the font family.
And I'm like, oh, this is nice.
Like this is a really cool.
- Yeah, I'm excited about it.
Let me throw one more bonus in here.
So if I change this to say,
edit this a Jupyter notebook cell here.
And if I go into the diff of,
if I go into the source control panel
after editing this Jupyter notebook cell,
I can actually see a real diff side by side
with those cells.
So that's something cool you can do
without having to install a full editor and things locally.
- Very cool.
Yeah, and it's a nice diff of the cell contents,
not like the JSON crazy diff.
- Yeah, you get the left, right with red, green, add, remove.
Yeah, and the outputs are squashed.
So you're not seeing a bunch of,
if you diff a notebook,
you'll see a bunch of XML and JSON being removed and added.
This is more of that rich.
- Take all of the various encoding language storage formats
and then jam them all together and then diff that.
That's fun.
Yeah, no, this is awesome.
This is a great view.
- Click it, I'm gonna use it.
- Indeed.
- So one of the things that I don't really edit
on in GitHub very much,
what happens like once you're done?
Does it create a merge request or just edit it in place?
- It makes a commit directly to the repository.
So I can just throw that right in there.
And--
- So you have to have,
obviously you have to have permissions.
You have to be one of the people
that can commit directly to that branch, right?
- Yeah, this is great.
I was so delighted when I saw it.
So I'm gonna definitely use this.
- Yeah.
- Nice.
All right, Brian, am I up on the next one?
- You are.
- All right on, let's move on to it.
Okay, I'm resisting the temptation to hit dot
and play around with the wake pie.
Instead, let me take you over here.
So we go to Python.
That's not Python bytes.
Close, but not exactly.
Gosh, man, don't even, why did I type com?
I've never, hold on.
Python bytes.fm, that's our domain.
So we're live streaming right now, by the way,
if you didn't notice.
If you go over here,
notice I've got Firefox that I'm using,
and it has this little shield.
And almost anything you go to,
man, I wanna go to a news site,
but let's go to CNN.
And you'll come over here,
and you'll see a bunch of stuff up here getting blocked,
like social media trackers, tracking content,
like look at that.
That's a ridiculous amount of gross Google Analytics,
Google Tag Services, Rubicon Project,
US East apparently, like that's bad, right?
So I've done a lot of work,
get us away from retargeting and tracking,
and we have no known trackers.
Now I'm running a VPN,
which probably blocked a bunch of the ones off of CNN.
So that was the ones that got through the blocking and stuff.
So it's really nice to not have all that stuff
and let people come visit the site
and know that we're not retargeting them,
we're not tracking them, we're not doing stuff.
We're just giving them a podcast
or same thing over on Talk Python Training
or Talk Python or whatever.
You go there, you get the content.
We offer things like a podcast with ads
that people can take and that's enough.
We don't need to like follow you around
for all sorts of creepy reasons, right?
The drawback is we don't have a lot of analytics, right?
We can get a sense about like download numbers
and things like that, but we can't report like,
well, in the last hour, since we talked about this thing,
here's the traffic, can we?
Or would we?
So Junction Apps over on Twitter said,
"Hey, you know what?
I heard you going on and on about the retargeting
of all these places and how you dropped it.
Have you heard about GoAccess.io?
Have either of you heard about this thing?"
- No, I hadn't either, but check it out is super cool.
So what it is, is it is a Google Analytics like service
that you install on your server.
And what it does, if I can put this image in a tab
so it doesn't go away.
What it does is it looks and tails your logs
and gives you real time analytics on your logs
rather than by looking at going through JavaScript
and hooking into people's browsers.
So no tracking, none of that stuff,
but you can come over here and in your terminal,
run it and get a real time view of your traffic,
your visitors, all the kind of stuff you would expect
from Google Analytics, visually as a graph like thing
in your terminal.
Interesting, huh?
- It's really cool.
- Yes, what kind of information are you getting?
- Well, probably the easiest way to find out
is they have a web view and have the terminal view.
And the web view is really generate a HTML file
and then just request it.
So there's not like a web server type thing.
But you go over here and click.
It says here, I'll give you the features real quick,
then open up the demo.
It says fast real-time millisecond based,
you know, latency updates written in C,
only uses in cursors as dependencies,
works on almost all the formats,
Nginx amongst the others.
Just set the log format and run it on your log,
got the terminal and the UI, the web UI bit.
So if you go over here, you can see,
like look at this off of just the log files.
So you can see things like here, I'll pull them up.
So you can go over and say,
well, what are the referring URLs?
Let me make that small so you can kind of see in here.
Unfortunately, here's the referring URLs.
So you can see in this example,
they were, you know, shop, internet, whatever, right?
These little, it's a fake site,
but you can come over here and like actually see graphs
as well as like grids and pages.
So like think Google Analytics,
but if you run a site and you can point this
against your logs and get real time information
in the terminal or as in this web view.
And yeah, it's pretty neat.
- And so do you have to install anything
or do you just run this and it finds the logs on your system
and pulls it all together?
- Yeah, you do have to install, let's see here.
So there's a getting started
and it says the way to get started
probably to use a package manager for your Linux machine
if you're running on Linux,
or you can get a Docker image and you run it.
And then what you do is you just simply run the command
against your log file and tell it what format
and boom, off it goes.
So you could set it up as a like a cron job or something
that will then generate the HTML file
and you could just refresh that, you know,
however often you want to, or run the terminal one.
- You could run it once a day too and save the report.
- Exactly, yeah, you don't need real time, real time.
You need just, yeah, sort of how's the day going
or something like that.
How was yesterday?
- Right, so like one of the things that I use
information like this about is
I don't really wanna track users.
I don't care about individual users,
but I do wanna know,
like I've got putting out different content on my blog
or on a podcast,
which ones are resonating with people?
- Yes, exactly. - And maybe do more of that.
- Yep.
So you can see, like there's a little bunch of options here.
Burn signs, host, requested files, they call it,
but it's really just URLs.
So you go over here,
and this would tell you sort of the traffic
across your various pages, right?
So this would be like your list,
this requested files URL, so the one you'd want.
Yeah, so anyway, I haven't set this up yet,
but it looks pretty neat,
and it could be worth checking out.
- Neat.
- And I guess even you could download your logs
and not install it on your server
if you really wanted, right?
You want this view,
but you don't actually wanna put it on your server
because putting stuff on the server, well, you know.
So you could download it
and then just run it against your logs locally.
- And you might be uploading your logs
to a storage account somewhere to on a cron job.
- Yeah, exactly.
You could push the logs out instead of running it there.
So a bunch of cool ways to use this,
but if people are running web apps
and they want more visibility into it,
this looks like a cool thing.
So thanks, Junction, for sending that over.
All right, off to you, Brian.
- I want to talk about keyboards a little bit.
So this was a topic recommended by somebody named Blaze,
Blaze, I think.
There's a package called kmk.
It's actually a collection of pieces of software,
but we're linking to the kmk firmware.
This is firmware for computer keyboards
written and configured in CircuitPython.
Got super excited about this.
I'm still excited about it.
The gist of it is,
if you've got a keyboard that runs a run circuit Python,
and it's powerful enough to handle your keyboard and stuff.
So there's a couple of tips in here.
There's a couple available through Adafruit
of different boards that would work.
We'll get into the details a little bit more.
But basically, you can configure a keyboard with a single Python file.
It controls both split keyboards,
two-piece keyboards, and single keyboards.
You can hook up macros,
things like chainable macros,
you can have key sequences built into one key,
or you can hook it up so that a key hitting multiple time,
you can hit a particular key three times in a row,
and you'll have one action versus something else.
Even controlling under glow and LEDs,
and backlights, and all that stuff,
Totally would be fun. I want to use this.
I don't know how. It seems like a lot of work though.
We're linking to the project and there's some information here.
There's some guides on how to get started.
Then we're also going to run,
I found somebody that ran this and he's got a video that walks through doing it.
But the gist of it is,
is there any keywords that do this right away?
You've got to take an existing keyboard,
rip out the existing circuit board and
replace it with one of the Adafruit boards,
and then reprogram it.
If you're the kind of person that's okay with ripping
the circuit board out of
your keyboard and replacing it with something else, that'd be great.
I actually wouldn't mind doing this.
I think that'd be fun,
but I'd like to know which keyboards I can do this with and which ones I can't.
I know there's a huge list of keyboards out there,
but even just a couple starter kits would be great to hear.
>> It really works well with this one and here's where
the CircuitPython board fits in there easily,
rather than it doesn't really go back in.
>> Yeah. One of the reasons why I'm bringing this up is I'd love
somebody from Adafruit or from anybody working on CircuitPython,
or the KMK team or somebody to maybe put
a couple more tutorials out to just say,
"Hey, this is how you do it."
I'd love it to have an off-the-shelf full keyboard,
even if it's small or whatever,
that it said, "Okay, here's how you do it.
Pull this circuit board out,
put this other one in,
it's like $40 on Adafruit,
and there you go.
You can try it and here's a sample of file that you would run it,
run just a normal keyboard usage.
Now, you can customize it.
because just getting back to a workable keyboard
seems already like a lot of work,
but it still looks fun.
I'd love to be able to hack a keyboard with Python.
>> Very cool. Dan, what kind of keyboard do you use?
>> Well, I'm a big fan of the thin keys,
the very light travel keys,
but I got the ergonomic keyboard.
Thin ergonomic Logitech, not into the mechanical ones.
>> I've got the Microsoft Sculpt ergonomic,
which I absolutely love.
Um, I know Brian's got even more exotic stuff that he's running over there.
I don't know if I can get mine up here.
I'll, I'll, I'll do the camera.
It's like it's mounted to the, no,
Oh, my junk too.
I've got a kinesis.
Yeah.
The kinesis inverted ones.
Those are super interesting.
What I would like to see would be some keyboard manufacturer saying
we're shipping a keyboard to you.
Oh, and you can program it with Python and basically do this for you as a package
thing and just, you know, build it out of these components.
That'd be fantastic.
Yeah, that'd be great.
Well, I think it'd be fun with, with everyone decking out their home offices
these days, if you could do a little bit of magic light show while you're presenting
or talking on a call, that would be really cool.
That'd be fantastic.
Yeah.
Hey, Brett Cannon's out there in the live stream.
Um, Dan, you may have heard of this guy.
Uh, Pablo, Pablo, Delgado has programmed his keyboard RGB lights to
color code, the build bot status for CPython.
I don't know which library uses.
That's awesome.
So like it's green if everything's good,
but it turns red if CI fails or something like that.
Oh, that's awesome, Brett.
Thanks for sharing.
- That'd be cool.
You know, I never really, I mean,
when I first saw the LEDs under the keyboards,
I thought, you know, yeah, gamers like it,
but I don't think I would probably have a use for it.
But now I'm jealous.
I want to light up things on my keyboard.
It'd be fun.
- Yeah, especially if you could program them, right?
Like this example here.
My mouse sits here and pulsates and changes color, but because it's on a Mac,
the software doesn't work and I can't do anything with it.
So it's just annoys me there.
It's a good mouse otherwise, but anyway.
So is it a windows only thing or what?
No, the mouse is perfect on Mac, but the software that lets you customize
and do interesting things to the colors doesn't work on the Mac.
Lame.
Super lame.
All right.
What is not lame is this last thing that Dan has got here.
because this thing has been blowing up on Twitter
is all of a day old with like 2000 GitHub stars.
And I was like, oh, this has got to be covered.
And then Dan, you were on it.
- Yeah, I just saw it yesterday.
And I was like, I have to talk about this.
So I know that when I've built web apps in the past,
one of the big frustrations I have is
that when you want to add something new to your database,
you need to add it to the SQL queries.
You need to add something to the backend code.
You need to add a piece to the API
that then returns that new object to users.
And then in your client code, you need to consume it.
And so there's all this repetition
that you're doing across your web app
every time you need to make a change to your data
or add a new object.
And that's very error prone as well.
And so things like SQLAlchemy,
you can use to write code that interacts with your database.
And then things like FastAPI,
you can use Pydantic to return models to your users,
to your APIs, but then now we had this thing
where you have SQLAlchemy models and Pydantic models,
and then you're translating back and forth between them.
And so Sebastian Ramirez, who just released yesterday
this new SQL model library, which looks just awesome
because it actually combines the schema
for talking to the database and speaking to your API
into one schema object that you write.
So what's really cool about this is that,
so the way you work with this is that you define
your objects, for example, he's got in the GitHub repo,
this hero class with an ID name, secret name, age,
and it's got some of the SQL alchemy type things
like it's your primary key, the ID is optional,
but it's defaults to non, it's primary key.
So what's really cool about it,
this class is both a SQL alchemy model and a Bidantic model.
I don't know how he did that.
He said there's some magic that's going on behind the scenes
and so what's really cool is that you can use this
to instantiate your database.
So you've got this hero class,
you can create objects in the database
by going hero one, hero two, hero three,
equals hero bracket and pass the name,
secret name, all the fields to the object.
And you can also return those same objects.
You can use that same hero class
and use it in your fast API.
So you can accept hero objects,
you can return hero objects.
And so that's one, you write that one schema
and you use it in multiple places.
- Yeah, what you have on the screen here for fast API
is response model equals the database entity,
which that then drives the OpenAPI documentation
in addition to just driving, yeah, exactly.
You got it right there.
So you can go there and it's sort of end to end
the same model, which I think is really great.
- Yeah, and so you can look at your,
with FastAPI, if you go to slash docs,
you get the Swagger UI.
And so you can see that same schema
with the ID name, secret name, age.
And what's really cool about that is that it also has,
This generates the openAPI.json.
And so you can use tools like OpenAPI Generator
to even generate client code in any different language
that you're using, like Python, JavaScript, Lua.
And so if you just went back to that original hero class
and added a new field, you could potentially
have it show up in all different layers of your application
with one--
- Right, including the consuming clients,
because they could regen off of the JSON schema, right?
- Yeah.
Yeah.
I think that's really cool. And one other really nice thing that Sebastian did here is that he
really emphasized making sure that in the editors that you have a good experience with autocomplete
because in the past, stuff like the Django ORM and the SQLAlchemy ORM, the editors have had to
write custom code to be able to have a good autocomplete experience for that. And so,
Sebastian used type hints really well throughout the design of this so that as you're returning
objects from the database, you actually get, you can, once you return that object from
the database, you actually get autocomplete on it. I can show that here.
Yeah, that's really cool. Because a lot of times you just get star star KWR, you know,
like, oh, thanks.
Yeah. So I got this statement select hero, where hero name equals hero name, and then
the object that returns, I can go hero. -- sorry.
>> Put it at the end of the line, maybe. Or the next line.
>> Yeah. So, I can access all the properties on the hero object. One cool thing about
how he did this, he used a proposal from Eric Trout, the author of PyRite, called the data
the class transform that it's this proposal
that basically you can annotate various objects
to say that they behave like data classes.
And so that's kind of the magic that allows
some of this dynamic behavior to show up in type checkers.
- I love it because so often you'll do a SQL alchemy query
or something and what you get back, it's so many layers,
it's lost what that type is.
- Yeah.
- It's like, ah, now I gotta like re-annotate it again.
- Like a search for everything,
look at all the different source code
in my code base and stuff like that.
This is really cool.
>> We've got some great comments in the chat.
Here's one. I swear Sebastian spends
as much time on his docs as he does his code.
Amazing talent.
We were talking about type hints in
the Azure experience as well.
Sebastian does a great job with
the onboarding experience as well as
the developer experience and a lot of
large companies could pay attention to what
this one person is doing,
making it easy for people to pick up a new tool. It's amazing.
>> I mean, look at the docs here.
This looks like a professional team wrote all this stuff.
This is incredible.
>> Instead, one very productive guy.
>> Then Brett, good question.
I want to know how Sebastian manages to release
a new very cool project every single year.
No kidding, man. He has a powerhouse.
He's changing how we do web development,
and it's just one person.
- Yeah, you know, I think I can speak to that
just a little bit, by the way.
If you look at the magic of FastAPI,
you look at what's happening here,
these are really nice things to work with,
but they're not from the ground recreations of what they are.
This takes Pydantic plus SQLAlchemy and makes it better.
FastAPI takes Starlet and Pydantic and makes them better.
Right, it's like the recombining of things
that are already really good into something better.
- Yeah, and some cool things that come
as a result of that repackaging.
So according to Sebastian,
this should support async database sessions out of the box
because that's something that SQLAlchemy supports,
Alembic migrations as well.
And in theory, it should be possible to integrate
with PostGIS and TS vectors for doing geo stuff
and full-text search with Postgres,
but he says he hasn't tested it yet.
- Yeah, I have no idea, but potentially,
async and await as well,
now that SQLAlchemy supports that.
- Yep.
- But again, this is a day old,
so we haven't really had a chance to dig in it too much.
I wanna highlight just a couple more comments.
Savannah on the livestream says,
"Sebastian's attention to developer experience
"is so awesome."
Yeah, I agree.
Keep it up, Sebastian.
And Rehan says, "It looks great for a toy case,
"but people make professional interior systems.
"Do they really wanna share the same types
"between their database and their REST API?"
That's a good question.
I was thinking about that as well.
One of the challenges that you can run into
when you just sort of say,
well, here's my data model out onto the internet as JSON,
and then especially taking it back,
is you can run into like situations
where you overexpose information
or you run into a mass assignment type of bugs
where values get set or you didn't expect them to be set.
So with Pydantic, you can do things like,
you have to call to JSON, but you can also,
or to dict, I can't remember, I think to dict,
but you explicitly opt in or opt out certain fields.
So you could do things like that about bringing those in.
So pretty neat, but yeah,
you gotta be a little bit careful about that.
But yeah, very cool stuff.
- You don't want your password hashes on your user object.
- Exactly, if you're gonna return your user,
you don't necessarily wanna exactly return,
say, the password hash, or God forbid,
not just the straight password.
You're not hashing it.
But that's a bigger problem, but still.
I wanted to bring up one more thing is his choice of heroes in his example.
Love these.
We've got Dead Pond, Spider Boy, and Rusty Man.
Hilarious.
Love it.
Yeah, those are great.
Well, so those are our six items.
Do we have any extras?
Got anything to share?
Ryan, sometimes I have extra, extra nine times here all about it.
I got none this time.
How about you?
Really?
I've got like two.
>> Bring on.
>> First one I wanted to bring up was a really fun episode.
People know I also do a podcast called Testing Code.
Episode 163, it's a talk with
Stefan Badul about pip install of local directory.
If you're doing anything where you do the pip install of
the local directory, definitely check that out,
or especially if you never knew that you could do that.
It's a good episode. The other thing I wanted to bring up is,
it's been like five episodes since I plug my book,
but Chapter 12 is up.
One of the things I got questions about for the first edition was,
the whole book is talking about testing packages,
and there's a lot more in the Python world than just packages.
So chapter 12 is a reaction to that.
It's testing scripts and applications.
So it's not a pivot.
If you don't have a pivot, installable package, you can still use
bytest to test it in chapter 12 directly addresses that.
So when you bring that up.
Awesome.
Alvaro out in the live stream says, how is the second edition testing about going?
Yeah.
It looks like chapter 12 is coming along.
Well done.
You're basically done, right?
You're on vacation.
Well, there were less than 10 chapters in the first book, but now I'm, I'm working
on chapter 13, planning on 17 altogether.
Um, it's going to come out in hard copy early next year.
So super.
I have one extra you, Dan.
Yep.
So one, one cool library that I wanted to share is a type for PI.
So we've been talking about types a lot lately.
Seems like it's a, it's a regular topic of conversation and, they, they can
provide a lot of benefits to your code base and to text editors, like VS code
or PyCharm.
But what happens if you want to retrofit or add
a bunch of types to a code base that's not typed already?
That's a big, daunting task.
And so I came across this library
shared amongst our team.
And what I thought was really cool about it
is that it's a state-of-the-art machine learning
model for inferring types.
So we've talked about before, hey,
wouldn't it be cool if we could just go generate
all the types for all the packages out there
that we could have great autocomplete on everything.
But it turns out you can't, because you can't do that
until you actually run the code and have
the objects to bind it to.
And so this machine learning model
is sort of the latest in a line of attempts
from different researchers to create a good machine learning
model for inferring types.
What I like about it is not only is it sort of best in class
in terms of its accuracy, is that the author of this machine
learning model, open sourced the training data set
with 4.3 million type annotations in it,
the training code.
So you can go in and actually use--
train this on your own code following
some of these very simple commands to train the model
and pre-process the data with your own code base.
Open sourced a VS Code extension,
so you can actually have developers using it.
It's not just some, hey, this is our results, QAD,
go read the paper.
It's actually something that you can use.
And so if you're looking at trying to retrofit
a bunch of types in your code base,
this is something you might wanna try out.
Just one sort of quick caveat
that the sample VS Code extension
uses the machine learning model
that's hosted on type4py.com.
And so if you're not working on an open source project,
you probably want to fork the extension
and stand up the machine learning model
using the web server that he links to.
- Yeah, that's a good bit of warning,
- Oh, this looks super cool.
It seems like one of those things
you could do a first pass, retrofit it,
and then go back and check it out,
run mypy against it.
You could even go to Pydantic
and use the validate decorator
and put that on all the things
and then run your tests.
The validate actually verifies the type annotations
really match the runtime behavior.
So yeah, a lot of neat things.
Excellent. - Cool.
- Brian, did you think that was funny?
- No, no, not funny at all.
- This might be funny.
Wait, we need something funny.
Yeah.
So we've been doing a lot of geek and poke lately and yeah,
this is a really good one.
So, you know, we talk about testing and we talk about continuous integration.
If you want to take that, like you go from testing to CI to the next level,
we're talking continuous delivery, right?
I'm going to get pushed to the production branch.
That's going to kick off the CI, which is going to kick off a deployment.
Glorious, right?
Yeah.
Well, we've got a cartoon around it.
So there's this man and woman developer pair
and they're just looking like perplexed at each other.
For five days, I've been doing nothing else
than trying to deploy this blinking application
on our production environment.
Title, continuous deployment.
That's one way to interpret that.
- Take it a bit literal.
- Very literal.
All right, well, hopefully that was more funny.
>> I've got a not very good joke,
but I thought it was funny anyway.
It was shared to us.
It was first from Carla,
not a robot, it's a great handle,
and told to us by Blue Fiddle Guy also.
Joke is, if a programmer gets an interview
because of a recommendation from a friend,
are they being passed by reference instead of value?
>> I love it. Definitely passed by reference.
Definitely. Well, this has been fun. So thanks everybody. Thanks Dan for showing up. Thank you for having me. Yeah. Thanks, Brian. Thanks guys
Thanks everyone out there. Bye. Bye
Thanks for listening to Python bites follow the show on Twitter via at Python bites
That's Python bites as in BYTES get the full show notes over at Python bytes FM
If you have a news item, we should cover just visit Python bytes FM and click submit in the nav bar
We're always on the lookout for sharing something cool
If you want to join us for the live recording, just visit the website and click "Live Stream"
to get notified of when our next episode goes live.
That's usually happening at noon Pacific on Wednesdays over at YouTube.
On behalf of myself and Brian Aukin, this is Michael Kennedy.
Thank you for listening and sharing this podcast with your friends and colleagues.